seven long weeks have locked down
unnecessary sacrifice it is now almost
two months since the people of this
country began to put up with
restrictions on their freedom your
freedom of a kind that we have never
seen before in peace or war it is a fact
that by adopting those measures we
prevented this country from being
engulfed by what could have been a
catastrophe in which the reasonable
worst-case scenario was half a million
fatalities I know you know that it would
be madness now to throw away that
achievement by allowing a second spike
we must stay alert we must continue to
control the virus and save lives
this a moment of danger moved too fast
or risk disaster although we have a plan
it is a conditional plan and since our
priority is to protect the public and
save lives we cannot move forward unless
we satisfy the five tests we must make
sure that any measures we take do not
force the reproduction rate of the
disease the are back up over one so that
we have the kind of exponential growth
we were facing a few weeks ago and to
chart our progress and to avoid going
back to square one we're establishing a
new Co vide alert system run by a new
joint biosecurity Center and that co vid
alert level will be determined primarily
by our and the number of coronavirus
cases and in turn that kobe the alert
level will tell us how tough we have to
be in our social distancing measures the
lower the level the few of the measures
the higher the level the tougher and
stricter we will have to be the
watchword is caution the pace measured
this is not the time simply to end the
lockdown this week instead we're taking
the first careful steps to modify our
measures
we now need to stress that anyone who
can't work from home for instance those
in construction or manufacturing should
be actively encouraged to go to work so
work from home if you can but you should
go to work if you can't work from home
and from this Wednesday we want to
encourage people to take more and even
unlimited amounts of outdoor exercise
you can sit in the Sun in your local
park you can drive to other destinations
you can even play sports
only with members of your own household
you must obey the rules on social
distancing and to enforce those rules we
will increase the fines for the small
minority who break them and so every day
with ever-increasing data we will be
monitoring the our and the number of new
infections and the progress we are
making and if we as a nation begin to
fulfill the conditions I have set out
then in the next few weeks and months we
may be able to go further nurseries
could reopen and some primer aged
children return to school the UK might
even have a holiday season at the
earliest by July and subject to all
these conditions and further scientific
advice if and only if the number
supported we will hope to reopen at
least some of the hospitality industry
and other public places provided they're
safe and enforce social distancing we
will come back from this devilish
illness we will come back to health and
robust health and there the UK will be
changed by this experience I believe we
can be stronger and better than ever
before more resilient more innovative
more economically dynamic but also more
generous and more sharing but for now we
must stay alert control the virus and
save lives
thank you very much the PM announcing
changes but so much we still don't know
well the Prime Minister appears to be
effectively telling millions of people
to go back to work tomorrow
but we haven't got the guidelines and we
don't know how it's going to work with
public transport so there's a huge
number of questions arising out of this
now there will be more detailed tomorrow
the promise is making a statement and we
will ask questions about that but as I
say what the country wanted was clarity
and consensus and we haven't got either
of those we've been in lockdown for a
long time and for some in Parliament and
for some members of the public to
patience is beginning to fray but if the
last few weeks have been very
black-and-white stay at home and save
lives the coming few weeks are going to
be rather gray there's no easy or
obvious route out of lockdown and many
of the questions people are asking don't
have any easy answers we all went into
lockdown together but the Prime Minister
knows there's not one simple route out
we all face different choices and
different risks Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster